[Music]
and fair are not news submitted by cash
rules everything around and they don't
want us to be greedy money like come on
we're gonna bug music we grew up with my
time you got balls in your mouth a
homeless man who tried to buy food with
a fake $20 bill has been sentenced to
six years in jail
oh no that's dope now he has food the
day that's dope but he can't roll
anywhere wait six years were just 20
bucks for fake in twenty bucks
someone else you do at a time it's
federal oh you something you can't
counterfeit they don't take you to jail
they just confiscate the money they tell
you get the [ __ ] out nothing wait what
let me tell you something because
because you know that McDonald's over
there so my friend and I was with my
friend's mom an inch she was gonna get
us some McDonald's when we were children
and then um she went in like bought some
food with a hundred dollar bill
and then they said oh this is fake ma'am
and she goes okay cuz I you know she got
it from another place or whatever she's
not [ __ ] fraud right there she goes
we have to call the police as she goes I
am at the creamy now I Eddie they're
just fighting back and forth and then
she would refuse for the cops to come
and embarrass her because should have
[ __ ] him no yeah I was like she's like
I'm willing to [ __ ] pay with other
money cuz like I didn't know that that
she was fake yeah I'd be pissed too is
that I received the fake hundred I got
duped
so now I'm gonna go to jail cuz I got
duped cuz that the bank if we received
anything we had it confiscated no matter
what but like let's say coming with a
fake hundred and deposit do you give me
a real hundred fail even if I go
no we don't do that at all yeah that's
uh it really sucks yeah so the thing I
wanted to tell you is that the headline
is a bit misleading oh no we got good
buddy
god damn so this man yes he's homeless
his name is levy he's 53 years old
from New York so he tried to use a fake
20 at a pharmacy to buy some toothpaste
and then I was a big criminal [ __ ] he
went to a nearby restaurant to try to
use it and both places they realized I
was faking so they called the cops
was it drawn with crayons yeah how was
it so noticeable that I was pink yeah
what makes you think this was fake oh I
don't know forest green crayon so
initially he was sentenced up to eight
years in prison but the thing is this
man has a [ __ ] ton of previous offense
there you go fake money so you have a
lot from fake money but this is a new
the bad guy like kidnapping that guy
really because he has a serious felony
convictions for attempted rape in the
first degree attempted robbery in the
first degree attempted criminal
possession of a weapon so exact crime
attempting all these go to jail right
and then what you and your for attempted
attempted attempted so you never
completed anything no I'm lazy as [ __ ]
me nice cause I try how can you be that
much of a loser that you even suck at
committing a crime
hey the first time I shoplifted I got
arrested would you would you shoplift
you [ __ ] criminal spring rolls what'd
you do
clothes Oh from where JCPenney oh that's
like 14 Oh
JCPenney clothes too huh not even is you
know know any better it's the clothes
with all the white people I got arrested
immediately I was like man I suck at
this do they put your picture up there
too don't give to this [ __ ]
slant-eyed big idea yeah did you walk in
with a trench coat like TIFF and [ __ ]
look all suspicious and [ __ ]
you had your hottie up like this I was
with a couple girls and I wasn't even
planning on stealing I was just there
and then they started stealing I was
like oh [ __ ] oh it's that [ __ ] what
do you call that mob mentality
peer pressure pressure oh they're better
cuz I don't get peer pressured right
yeah you do yeah you do we pressure you
all the time when it's food what is this
beat up David Dave what's going on here
right Dave Oh be like night lunch and
then I'm like mmm and you're not
yesterday I ate a sandwich and then he
was I damnit you hear what who gets the
bottom as well hey Robin I don't think
that's real pressure either what is peer
pressure then I don't want to drink
something right and then it's a come on
drink we're all drinking let's do it
let's just all have fun like no no I'm
okay we bigger the height in Hawaii to
pillboxes oh yeah when we got you up to
the top that was right wasn't peer
pressure that was me being a down-ass
[ __ ] because I don't want to be the
reason why other people don't have fun
David as Adonis pitched yeah I kick and
I scream but I still [ __ ] do it
I hate training more time I've been
doing for a year you hate it no oh you
do by yourself yeah it's fun yeah it's
fun especially Fridays yeah I don't get
peer pressured I pressure myself doing
selfish self pressure dude it's like
your diamond dude [ __ ] all that
cultures into a diamond oh yes oh this
dude he has 30 prior criminal
convictions including five felonies in
25 mister are [ __ ] working and he's
still off into the streets how awesome
so the judge actually reduced his
sentence from eight years to six three
to six years why he probably wants to go
back to jail the defense and all that it
was they were saying like you know what
he was trying to get basic necessities
with this fake currency he was gonna
brush his teeth so he could rape a woman
after kissing their dude [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
what was its basic necessities food food
toothpastes and orange chicken no speaka
you went into a Chinese restaurant
orange chicken why do I just picture him
just a fast-food restaurant all right
well first of all they went to a
restaurant he went to a restaurant and
then he approached another fast-food
restaurant that's me oh stop by the
police your honor
this person needs to brush that tape so
they should be free people let's feel
bad for the person that tried to rape
fifty women at one time but did they
change and they just wanted some to get
out know those and then those most of
his convictions were in recent years too
because what the [ __ ] the first one was
back in nineteen eighty one majority of
the ones that he has now it's all about
balance okay so like let's say like oh
this person robbed 50 homes but he also
fed fifty dogs yeah he rescued fifty
people from poverty I heard you know
those forest fires that we had recently
the Wolseley fires is that what is
coming yes okay but those they were they
were a lot of inmates were sent over
there to do that fires yeah we're we're
just time yep yeah so the good the good
behavior ones get to go out in help and
then it reduces their time they know
they're not gonna run away did you guys
notice that inmates that we saw when we
went by creating three inmates they're
like collecting trash I was like you see
that to me yeah me too and then there
was a guard oh no I was I was on my own
dollars like I was speeding free there's
three inmates with uh with the guard oh
really I had no idea during break
jumpsuits yeah they told us they were
walking right oh I would listen to some
Japanese [ __ ] it I was going to have a
[Music]
yeah there's like this banner Japanese
people they love music man like I feel
like Lady Japanese people when they when
they hone in on something they do it to
like the best that they can
cuz it's Japanese people yeah man yeah
damn it Japanese people I hate them you
guys go hiking and biking we're just
never gonna go bike with him never again
taking booked it and I was dying I could
not catch up yeah we were like cool
we're he's gonna wait like we're all
still getting on our bikes and he would
took off and yeah it's like jus yeah and
then we were like okay well maybe he's
trying to get out of the way and he just
kept going so me and Bart like bar had
tight gun he's like trying to catch up
and I'm trying to catch up to Bart's I
could see its high coming tonight Luke
was trying to catch up to do and I was
trying to catch up to Isaac and Kasey
was just like staying with me in the
back can I just say something though we
were like what the finai bike riding is
that's how you fell with Muriel exactly
so I was his little helmet was coming
off my bike ride when I bike ride with
Mary alright that's how we bike ride on
my you ready this is what I hear the
[ __ ] Super Mario this is and so for
me like when I bike I the speed that I
was going is substantially slower than
Muriel's so I assume that that's slow
and that's the piece trying to break up
dude you're a liar because we've been
bike riding with Mario's
she was not that bad but I always go to
the pace of her so when we bike ride
she's [ __ ] gone dude yeah so were you
bro
you know wanted to enjoy the beach
like it's passed out in the back
segways are fun but now I know that when
we bike ride now that's that way didn't
work that's what you said for the right
back waited for you cuz me and him more
ahead and I turned on my okay well let
me get you a woman like you know there
was there one of those criminals got
loose and I and I didn't see felt him
and you don't want you fatty I went
through and I slid right and I chucked
the bike at him and it hit him in the
face I started punching him in the face
he went to jail for fishing from New
York I do have a bike on top of each
other in English I wouldn't be surprised
or pool there's a lot of bums that have
that you know huh there's a lot of bums
that have that another have like a motor
[Laughter]
[Music]